the starks reigned as kings for
thousands of years even withstanding the
invasion of the andals
as the southern kingdoms fell and the
children of the forest were driven away
the north stood strong
maintaining its religious customs and
its way of life eventually the reign of
the kings of winter came to an end with
the coming of aegon the conqueror
after aegon and his dragons destroyed
the combined armies of the reach and the
rock at the field of fire
king tauren stark bent the knee and
swore fealty to the targaryen dynasty
in order to spare the destruction of
winterfell
and his people
he was forever after known as the king
who knelt
as a reward for his submission
aegon named tauren lord of winterfell
and warden of the north
the north is the oldest and largest of
the seven kingdoms but house stark has
not always held it
when bran the builder raised winterfell
and founded our line we were vassals to
the barrow kings who claimed descent
from the first king and thus dominion
over all the first men
but after the long night it was our
house who built the wall and set the
night's watch to guard the realms of men
whilst our king sat in his barrow
my ancestors eventually revolted waging
what singers call the thousand years war
to free our lands
other families joined us recognizing
that the north is a cold and hard land
and needed a king who served its people
before himself
finally the last barrow king bent the
knee and house stark became the kings of
winter
yet we were kings in name only for by
then the north had fractured into petty
kingdoms and my ancestors would struggle
to unite it again for thousands of years
roderick stark wrestled an ironborn lord
for bear island and granted it to house
mormont when he won
a younger son of our family carlon stark
won his own keep after he put down a
rebellion and founded house karstark one
of the most powerful in the north
when the mandalees were exiled from the
reach my ancestors shielded them and
gave them a home at the mouth of the
white knife
in return for holding the river against
pirates and invaders
now they're one of the wealthiest houses
in the north
i'm not so naive to pretend that the
entire north welcomed stark rule
the last war king was slain at sea
dragon point along with all his sons and
beasts
the last marsh king died at the hands of
king rickard stark and house reed has
held the swamps of the neck ever since
houses greenwood towers amber frost
none survive today as more than names
and dusty old books
but my ancestors never wanted to destroy
their foes root and stem
the umbers of last half and the glovers
of deepwood mott bent the knee and
became loyal vassals of house stark
the red kings of house bolton wore
cloaks made from the skins of stark
princes they flayed and one of the
boltons was even known as the red arm
because he liked to plunge an arm into
the bellies of captive starks and pull
out their entrails with his bare hand
the north deserved to be wiped clean of
them yet my ancestors spared them after
their defeat because they believed the
north couldn't afford to fight itself
any longer
time soon proved them right
when the andals swept into westeros they
obliterated all the kingdoms of the
first men except the north
each of the southern kingdoms fought the
invaders on its own but the north fought
as one
when the andals tried to sail up the
white knight the mandalis fell on their
ships
when the andals tried to march an army
through the neck the reeds fell on their
soldiers
king theon stark even sailed his own
army to the andal homeland for vengeance
and slew hundreds of andal warriors
when he returned he planted their heads
on spikes along our coasts
a warning to other would-be conquerors
the warning was heeded for thousands of
years until aegon the conqueror the
south had already fallen to aegon and
his dragons only the north remained
my ancestor king torrenstark marched the
north down to the trident and beheld
aegon's army larger than tauren's own by
half and with three dragons circling
overhead
many northern bannermen wanted to attack
anyway claiming northern valor would
carry the day
others wanted to fall back to moat
kaelin and make a stand there
but tauren had heard how the armies of
the rock and the reach had burned on the
field of fire and had seen the fires
still glowing beneath the rubble of
harrenhal
he knelt and laid his ancient crown at
aegon's feet
and rose a king no more but lord of
winterfell and warden of the north
some northerners still sneer at my
ancestor as the king who knelt
forgetting that because of tauren
they're alive today to smear
their ancestors didn't leave their
burned bones at the trident and their
twisted swords didn't fill aegon's new
throne
brandon the builder founder of house
stark raised winterfell with giants over
8 000 years ago or so nursemaids tell
all the children of the north
the children nod wide-eyed unaware of
the lesson forced on them that if even
giants obeyed a stark so too should they
but like every other castle winterfell
was built in pieces over thousands of
years
the first men settled there because of
the hot springs that bubbled through the
ground the water and the heat helped
them survive the northern winters and
they built defenses to keep it for
themselves
nobody raised the castle all at once
probably nobody meant to raise a castle
at all
in those days the starks were not the
greatest house in the north and
winterfell was not the greatest castle
maraton was the oldest dating to the
first king and the starks fought the
barrow kings for a thousand years
greywater watch was like the krannert
men themselves the strangest
only marriage subdued its marsh kings
but the greatest rival to winterfell was
always the dreadfort and my ancestors
the red kings of house bolton if tales
can be believed we fought from the long
night until the andals came
because of us winterfell raised its
first walls
when we took and burnt the castle anyway
winterfell built more keeps more walls
more guard towers they expanded the
granaries and larders to survive our
sieges they tended the godswood to win
favor with the old gods against us
as the castle grew more farmers and
villagers flocked every winter from
across the north to huddle under its
walls
raising the winter town
in the spring these villagers would find
themselves marching in the stark armies
to fight against us the greatness of
winterfell is as much our doing as the
starks
but in the end neither its stone walls
nor its tall keeps and iron gates could
save winterfell at its height it could
have lasted a year under heavy siege
but a handful of ironborn seized it in
the night
while its lord the king in the north was
playing in the south
my dagger ended his reign
as a boy looking out from my father's
castle
i thought the sun could never set on the
north so vast did it seem
part of me still does
the north is by far the largest of the
seven kingdoms and can fit the other six
inside it
not that the others care
gold and damp that's how the southerners
see the north
but without the cold a man can't
appreciate the fire in his hearth
without the rain a man can't appreciate
the roof over his head
let the south have its sun flowers and
affectations
we northerners have home
mine was once winterfell
the ancient seat of my
father's family house stark who have
ruled the north since the first men and
were once the kings of winter
growing up
lady catelyn made sure i knew i wasn't
the stark
no matter how much blood i shared with
her true born children
but where their name rules over the
north mine is the north
snow
our land stretches from the wall down to
the neck a narrow land that devises from
the rest of westeros
legend has it that the children of the
forest flooded it in their war against
the first men
if that's true
every northman owes them a debt of
gratitude
the swamps of the neck are as good as
the wall for keeping out unwelcome
armies and if the swamps don't deter you
the chronic men should
small
shy people who rarely leave those swamps
and who follow house reed the
gatekeepers of the north and among the
most important and loyal bannermen of al
stark
also a bit strange
i heard their author felt he wants as a
child
it's like no other lords
ancient and dark
they swear by earth and water
by bronze and iron and by ice
and fire
where house reed holds the gate to the
north house mandalay holds the port
white harbour the closest thing to a
southern city we have governed by the
closest thing to a southern family we
have generations ago the mandalays were
driven from the reach but the starks
gave them their land in return for
failty
now white harbour is the richest city of
the north and the mandal is the richest
family
not in gold and silver like their
southern counterparts but in fish grain
and trade
as for the other great northern houses
the starks brought them into the fall
during the age of heroes
a stark wrestled nineborn for bear
island and gave it to the mormons
a stark granted a keep and land to a
younger son carlon in return for putting
down a rebellion
his family then grew up into the car
starks
starks fought the wildlings and their
kings beyond the wall beside the umbers
of last earth thus earning their failty
boltons
but then they were the bane of the north
a few were even rumored to wear their
enemies flayed skins as clarks
but after centuries of war
they too bent the knee
and so how stark became the kings in the
north but never forgot that they weren't
the north when aegon and his dragons
landed on westeros
the kings of the rock and the reach sent
all their men to die to defend their
grounds
tauren stark knelt
to spare his people the same fate
he placed duty above pride